do you believe that every business is a
media company today yes yes what kind of
content what does it mean what kind of
content they can create or should create
what's your take on a media for a small
business so does anybody know what was
the first piece of content I ever made
do you know the story behind it I I've
never told the story anybody kind of
knows a story or no you kind of remember
the first piece of content watches
you're going to flip out when I tell you
this this is one I knew I have to create
content
so one guy says Pat
there's this thing called blogging
I said what's a Blog
he said it was like there's the block
and there's the Vlog
blog I thought it was the guy from uh
Ghostbusters dude I thought it was like
uh wasn't it like a scary character
movie back in the days called blob or
blah I don't know what that was who
remembers anybody knows what I'm talking
about what was the guy's name
blob okay so I thought it was like a
movie he says blogging is writing
vlogging is video right I said cool okay
go write a blog and there's this website
called wordpress.com so cool
but I'll get to it this is 11 years ago
okay
so I go watch this movie called
Limitless who numbers Limitless anybody
has seen Limitless with Bradley Cooper
Okay so
so I could watch this movie I come on my
damn this was a sick movie
so I'm online I'm like is there such a
thing as nzt okay
everybody knows what's NCT and the movie
that's the pill he takes where you can
kind of like so I write an article
titled did Einstein take nzt
and I just write three paragraphs on
this article
I wake up in the morning
I got hundreds of emails I'm like what
the hell are they everybody's asking me
the same question do you sell nzt do you
know anybody that has NCT I'm like and
so now at this point look how amateur I
am I am now conspiracy in my mind this
[__] is real
there is something
they know they know they're reaching out
to me let me ask them and then I
realized no everybody read this article
because I wrote the article the night
the movie came out and it went viral
okay so a lot of people think my first
content that went viral was the life of
an entrepreneur in 90 seconds it was
this article about nzt so I was like wow
the power of this I just had so many
great conversations with people about a
movie okay we have to create content so
now
how many of you are not comfortable on
the camera reason if you don't like the
camera okay how many guys are very good
writers you like writing and you're a
very good writer fantastic how many have
a very good voice very good voice sing
for us say something if you got a good
voice right you raise your hand a raise
and if you got a very good voice the
reason if you got a really good voice
okay so look how many got all three
you're good with video you're good with
writing and you got a great voice raise
your hand okay you're the trifecta
you're like Justin Timberlake you can
sing dance and act right
so whether you are or not
pick one of them
today to start off with
if you don't like camera don't worry
about I didn't bother I wrote three
years before I made a single video
I just wrote
okay
do audio if you don't want to do video
but if you do video you can do all three
but if you don't
I'll give you a few few reasons um I'll
give you the pain and then I'll sell you
the dream let me first give you the pain
because you guys seem like the type of
group that likes pain Roofing you like
pain
Okay so
how many of you your parents have
footage of you when you were a kid
raise your hand raise your hand how many
you remember the first time you saw it
and you're like man that's pretty cool
me as a kid who remembers that moment
when you saw it right okay so check this
out one day my dad was 80 today he calls
me says she gotta come home families
coming over you will not believe what
they set me from Iran
and I'm fired up because I'm all about
this history of Iran so I'll come at
home early what do they send us from
Iran we go home
we found
video footage from 45 plus years ago no
way
this is sick now my sister is six years
older than me so I'm sitting there and
they play the clip of my sister at 13
months old
and I'm watching this I'm like oh my God
that is so cool she's so cute but guess
what I'm thinking the entire time
I can't wait to see videos of myself
and I'm thinking my video is gonna have
better quality production it's going to
be sick so I'm just sitting on waiting
I'm like okay that's great what else no
that's it
so like any old more maybe like
no no that's it
so where's the videos of me
oh we do
we didn't we didn't record you
bro you invite me to come see videos of
my sister I'm six years younger you
don't have a single piece of content of
Me no
isn't the quality supposed to be better
but we we forgot with you
we forgot with you that's when I knew
my sister was a favorite I knew that day
by the way
amigoso parents and your kids are not in
the room raise your hand how many guys
got favors but you'll never tell them
you never tell them I never who's the
favorite all of you I love you
I love you I love all of you right
so here's a question
how many guys have content of your
parents when they were kids
if you do you're probably in your 20s
and 30s
how many guys
found a journal of your grandparents
that are no longer here with us
raise your hand if you actually I want
you to look around real quick look
around don't look at me see Ray can you
stand up if you found Journal of your
grandparents just stand up because we
are not like you this is a very special
community
let me ask you how many of you read
through that journal and got emotional
when you're at a certain moment in their
lives of what they were going through
yes or no okay to the rest of us that
don't have that how many of us would
love to get that journal can I ask you a
question what would you pay for that
journal
honest question what would if I right
now told you boom Larry bring them up
and they brought up the journals of your
grandparents honest question put a price
point to it what would you pay for that
journal
what would you pay for that journal give
me a dollar amount
what's the number I'm asking
50 Grand
how many guys would gladly pay 50 Grand
to see those journals of your
grandparents right guess what don't do
that to your grandkids
did you understand what I mean by that
yeah creating content isn't just for
business
creating content in life there's a
Jewish proverb that says every man
should do three things
write a book
plant a tree have a son
what's the premise behind all these
three things
to build something that outlives you
creating content today all were caught
up on is the fact that we're going to
make money writing content we're going
to make money if we make a video we're
going to make because if this video goes
by I want to be so famous
yeah it's a different story your kids
are only going to watch that stuff your
grandkids are one they're going to say
wow my mom at 42 was going through this
mom what was going on in 2023 when you
wrote this article what was going on in
2023 when you wrote this video how did
were you is this when you guys were
going through a hard time with Dad yes I
feel it in the way you said this in the
video mom look at the date here watch
this and you're sitting there having a
moment with them in 2068. that's cool so
on that selfish side make it because
they're going to want it on the business
side
30 years ago of Steve Jobs wanted to
break a story to everybody outside of
his annual meeting that he would do he
would go find a magazine that was super
edgy and he would call the header in
Chief Playboy he would say I'm launching
a product I'm writing an article I want
you to come out to the headquarters in
Cupertino interview me we're about to
make a big announcement I want her to be
on Playboy okay great we're on our way
today if a person wants to make an
announcement what do they do
you put it out there you launch it
the great equalizer years ago
was the gun
where a guy my size and a 79 year old
lady who was 5 117 pounds were
officially equal the moment she goes
like this
we're the same size
we are officially the same size okay
today
Logan Paul
Jake Paul
Tate
Dana White UFC Trump Obama
I can go on and on and on
everybody today
who can get their message out there is
competing with the bigger guys and the
bigger guys can no longer bully the
little guys
the little guys who know how to use the
most powerful weapon in the world today
this right here
if you know how to use the most powerful
weapon in the world today you can
compete against the biggest guy in your
industry when we started our insurance
company all the big insurance companies
were advertising commercials of whales
anybody knows the insurance company that
puts a will in it
have any one of you ever bought a life
insurance policy because you saw a will
in a commercial
how funny is that right or Snoopy or
will or all these other animals or a
duck sitting there saying tell a story
tell a story of what happened with a
family who bought an insurance policy
tell a story of what happened with
somebody who was struggling with roofing
issues and they came to you but talk to
me from this standpoint too many videos
are just making their argument through
this I was having a debate the other day
talking to a group of Pastors in the
Christian Community and they're like hey
we kind of want to get marketing to
improve you know can you come and help
us out I said look let me just tell you
who's doing it the best I said Mormons
are doing it the best
I said you ever seen Mormon's YouTube
any Mormons in here by the way resident
if you're Mormon LDS from Utah Mormon we
got one here anybody else right there
have you guys ever seen Mormon's YouTube
channel go look at their YouTube channel
amazing
look at the way Mormons tell stories
look at the way they're marketing their
stories look what's going on to
Christian denomination church today look
what's going on at Catholics today they
don't know how to tell stories I'm not a
Mormon by the way so I'm not pitching
you to go be a Mormon all I'm saying to
you is look at the way people are
telling stories everybody is trying to
convince people through here this
doesn't work
this does not work
this is what works if you can get me to
watch a piece of content from you and
say men
every time I watch her
she just comes across by the way why do
you guys follow this guy he's got 60
some thousand Subs he's number one guy
in the roofing business content creator
why do you guys follow this guy's
content go ahead tell us why do you
follow his content raise your hand if
you believe him do you believe him does
he come across as trustworthy do you
connect with him because he wants you to
run a business like you who sold it and
transition do you connect with them do
you like the fact that he calls out the
bigger bullies who've been bullying the
smaller businesses do you like the fact
that he does that for you how did he all
of a sudden get 1200 of you guys to come
out here and all these people paying
sponsorship to come to a Convention
Center in the number one convention city
in America how did he do it he told
stories
and other people said I relate to this
guy
I like this guy let me find out a little
bit more about what's going on over here
now let me buy a ticket to come here let
me go and take my teammates over there
so content creation if you're afraid of
it figure out one of the three methods
to start but don't wait too long to
start and don't over complicate things
there's two things either be Niche which
is Roofing or something you know a lot
about for me
my first set of videos If you you want
to know how not to do it go watch my
first hundred videos I talk about so
many random things finally I won't like
this what I know a lot about is running
business then I started writing down
things that I'm interested in gradually
to bring them into my audience I started
doing bodybuilding interviews 30 million
views I started doing mob interviews a
few hundred million views I started
doing CIA FBI interviews I started doing
JFK assassination research I started
Iran videos China videos all of a sudden
now we got a PVD podcast and I was like
now it's so wide but we started off with
a niche so one Niche industry two what
do you know a lot about that I could
connect with you on what is it is it
Sports is it cards is it UFC is it
painting is it a artwork what is it you
would be amazed that audience is going
to show up and find you out of nowhere
that's how this business works but you
have to at least start off with your
first piece of content
foreign
[Music]